we're talking your teams everyone I
think by now probably knows that my team
Allegiance is Arsenal Football Club so
I'm absolutely delighted to be joined by
the man who transformed my club from the
the mediocre minnows of the Premier
League to the all-conquering Champions
because he brought this strange guy in
called arsene Wenger who we'd never
heard of and he'd been in Japan who are
like he's lost his mind this guy but
David Dean knew what he was talking
about he was a vice chairman of Arsenal
and the rest is history won the league
three times in eight years a host of
other trophies and became the best team
in the world probably ever and David
Dean is with me now David great to see
you and Nadia's kindly agreed to stay
with us David a lot of speculation well
first of all your reaction to the result
tonight England what do you think very
satisfied it was we started off very
slowly as a bit of a pedestrian first
half but certainly woke up in the second
half and it was a very good accomplished
performance and I'm delighted for the
team and for all the fans who would have
thought that we could score nine goals
at a World Cup and Harry Kane wouldn't
get any there you go well there's a good
problem for Southgate to have everyone's
banging in goals apart from the guy who
normally does that's right but you're
you're only as good as your last game
you've got to keep winning
what does Southgate doing now with this
team because he now is a lot of
competition for places he brought Phil
foden back in yes I think Godfrey read
my column in the sun I'm not sure uh
demanding fodenster but he was great
tonight uh Marcus rashford was on fire
today I don't see how he can drop
rashford but he can't play rashford
Sterling Sakia Odom and Kane and mount
and grillish yes appears were all
frustrated managers aren't we and I can
see Senegal in the next round we've got
right on Sunday evening I think who
would you put in that front five I'm
very pleased I'm not the manager because
he's got a he's got to stand up to be
counted and he'll be judged on his
before on the team's performance what do
you think who would you put now if you
were Gary Southgate obviously came start
so who do you put around Kane
who do you ruin their World Cup
I think Russia has been doing very well
so I'll choose him and then I'll sucker
because I'm also Arsenal fans I think
you've got to play soccer on the right
voting him behind Kane rashford I mean
one of them's going on the left
and they can't vote can they it's a
pleasant problem to have yeah luxus it's
a good problem let's turn to the World
Cup more generally because David you've
been one of the top football Executives
for many decades now you know how it all
works let's start first of all with all
the noise around FIFA as an organization
you've dealt with them over the years
how much of the criticism is Justified
well I think perhaps initially certainly
when the bid process went on it was
definitely flawed there's no question
about that however that was 12 years ago
we have to move on we've decided to put
a team into the World Cup we've
qualified and we've got to give them the
best support we possibly can and I
really feel sorry for people who haven't
come out here because they're missing a
lot they're missing a phenomenal
tournament I have personally seen 15 out
of the last 16 World Cups my first World
Cup was 19. 15 out of the line six out
of six
no no I'm talking about World Cups I
don't mind the games how many games four
a day I mean I've been Heaven I've been
obviously going around with us we've
been seeing four games a day out of all
the games we've only missed two out of
uh I just want to interrupt because the
man chanting here's Morgan is a legend
and I wouldn't like to think the cameras
hadn't picked that up so no just want to
make sure we got that on camera you sure
he didn't say leg end how many World
Cups have you been to World Cups have
been I the first one was 1966 at Wembley
when we won it I was one yes I've been
to 15 since then missing out one in 1982
in Spain otherwise everyone 15 World
Cups and Peters out of all of them this
has to rank right at the top this is as
good if not better than any other it is
funny enough I saw Graham Sooners this
morning he said the same thing it's been
phenomenal the whole organization of it
you know people are quick to criticize
and slow to praise Qatar deserve a lot
of praise for the way they've put it on
last night we went to the game at
Lucille Stadium it finished at five to
twelve I was back in the hotel at
quarter past 12.
politics ever get involved with sport
I don't I don't think so because where
does it end sport is a sport football is
a sport and we've got to treat it as
such and once you start introducing
politics or in trouble because we could
have 32 countries here with different
political messages where does it end all
of which have their own problems and you
know FIFA do deserve some credit and I
think Johnny Infantino particularly the
president obviously everybody gets it
it's easy to criticize somebody but it's
been a magnificent World Cup you can't
ever I mean the accommodation has been
great the transport has been I mean look
I think
the problem it felt to me was that press
conference he gave where he slightly
overegged the souffle he went on a bit
too passionately and when he began
telling everybody I'm gay I'm Arabic and
I'm everything else I was like where's
this going to finish he's like he seemed
to be everything but don't forget he has
been a bit he's been a bit hammered by
certain members of the press sure uh I
don't think you're amongst that but are
you yes what did you make of it another
I mean it's a hard job running a FIFA
um but I knew what he was trying to say
he was trying to say look there's a lot
of hypocrisy which I think there is I've
been on this myself but the he probably
slightly over did it yeah definitely I
think you know
I don't think he knows how it feels to
truly be uh and someone else's shoes
that way he always explaining that but I
think his message was kind of that
that we should be a bit more tolerant
you know and then and football is the
beautiful game that can unite and that's
and it it's for everyone uh and this
region deserves also to experience World
Cup and I think it's going to do great
things for the region not only for Qatar
um you've had a bit of criticism back
home yeah everybody who seems to come
here I got criticized for coming I don't
care whether you think I should not I've
been in the Middle East a lot in my life
I like the Middle East a lot of people
here I think they deserve a bit more
respect for what they're doing here and
that doesn't mean you ignore the areas
where they could certainly be improving
but I don't think England's in any great
shape to install their moral virtue on
other countries what do you think of
this argument about the morality of it
all
uh honestly as you said I I've to be
honest I don't really understand that
for me
this was the decision that was been
taken 12 years ago and now that we're
here we should try to make the best out
of it I think every there's problems
everywhere and and trying to highlight
one thing
extremely for so long time I think but
too much uh what I see in the way is
that football is a great tool to bring
change to educate to improve just
the fact that we're sitting here talking
about about you know what could be
better that's a
you could spin any of these numbers like
I mean there are so many millions of
migrants at two and a half million
migrants here how many countries would
allow 90 odd percent of their population
to be migrants right and they come here
to earn more money than they could from
the countries they come from in almost
every case yes there have been a number
of deaths yes those should be
investigated yes the conditions have had
to be improved so therefore that's an
emission thing's not as good as they
should be but I was speaking to some
women yesterday Qatari women everyone in
Qatar gets free education for example I
didn't know that they said there's
gender pay equality throughout all
official bodies including the government
um and so on and so on it's not quite
how people may be in Denmark or England
think it is here
no I don't think that's correct exactly
you know I think some of the western
media has been taking one thing and kind
of spinning it and a lot of people that
come here they say well I was imagining
something totally differently and then
to be a very Frank you know it's not
because I'm trying to build your like
you know paint your picture does not but
I'm just whether it deserves credit you
should give it and for me this woke up
so far has been brilliant
David
putting on a World Cup it's an
unbelievably difficult thing and I think
we can all agree that so far it's run
very very well no traffic problems the
stadiums are out of this world if you
want a drink you can get one very easily
in restaurants and bars all over the
town hotels there's no real problem with
that I personally rather like the fact
the fans can't all get drunk in cyber
stadiums because I was at the Wembley
Euros final last year and frankly it was
a complete disgrace yeah I agree with
you and the capacity they're running now
at 97 capacities of actually every
stadium is full every day that
atmosphere tonight America Iran was
probably the best atmosphere so far
there you go well I thought Argentina
Mexico was really rich I mean that was
wonderful they're nearly 90 000 people
and a lot of the Argentinian fans the
Mexican fans were side by side you know
and I mean that for FIFA this has been a
phenomenal success it really has what
about what about the allegations which
are swirled around FIFA for decades of
corruption you've you know all these
people yeah we know that a lot of them
have been caught with their fingers in
the till so the corruption has clearly
been real and clearly been going on
should FIFA go through a wholesale
Reformation do you think well no but I
think In fairness when Johnny and fan
don't forget he inherited that mess and
to his great credit I think he's
actually cleaned up the show so I think
he deserves something for that for the
way FIFA currently being run of course
everybody's going to be critical he's
got 211
everybody not everybody's going to be
satisfied that goes with the territory I
mean there's huge money in a World Cup
and where there's huge money there's
always corruption peers we can be
cynical but meanwhile this tournament
will gross something like seven billion
dollars right you've got to say that is
a huge success
it's wonderful it's when it all gets
recycled back into football around the
world I certainly think that if you're
walking around Qatar I know you've had
to sadly to leave to beat your mother's
funeral but I've been here for five days
now just walking around and Milling
around the regular fans of all around
the world a you get a sense of the scale
of a World Cup the sheer volume of
countries supporters walking around with
flags and everything secondly a lot of
Happiness no real incidents no fighting
no vomiting in mystery I mean it's been
a very feels like a very safe and happy
event to me yeah definitely I've been
enjoying it as you said you know the
atmosphere of the vibe is very very nice
pleasant
um safe the fans are enjoying themselves
The Fan zones are full uh I've been a
couple of times you know Fan Festival
um yeah what's it been like to be a
woman in Qatar for you
oh wait for me it's been the same as it
is everywhere you know I felt safe and
like it's like in U.S and Europe um as I
said it's it's it's very hard to point
fingers if you haven't really experience
in yourself and this is a way for us to
educate you know I think football had
that power to educate C because you you
read something or you heard something
without actually being coming from
Afghanistan where you were deprived in
education by the Taliban and now
millions of young girls in Afghanistan
are once again being deprived in
education by the Taliban to come to a
country like Qatar which is a small
country but where education is free for
all including all girls
I mean that's not a thing to turn our
noses up at no I think that's amazing I
think that's a great example to set that
should that should be a norm anywhere
you know free education
but it's unfortunately that's David case
who is going to win the World Cup come
on you know your football uh well I
think Nelly wasn't far wrong when she I
think you went for Brazil Brazil
I think France won't be too far away I
don't think Portugal will be far away
they won't be they look good and I have
to tell you yesterday was one I mean we
are seeing I mean I'm obviously I'm
going around a lot with our sin we saw
we're seeing four games a day and
yesterday after the Ghana game uh where
they were playing Korean it was a
wonderful game of football yeah we were
coming to Lucille for the final fourth
game I said to Miles saying are you
ready for another game he said I'm ready
for two
[Laughter]
with this will be unique you will not
see another world cup with four games
if we win all the next games we can win
it
why we can beat Senegal then we're in
the quarterfinals right and who knows
anything can happen in a World Cup
you've been there you've been in the
European final yeah
anything can happen that's football you
know yeah
listen thank you particularly for coming
back uh to the World Cup that takes a
lot of guts and I send my very best to
you and all your family as well and I
can see the spirit of both your father
and your mother and you without ever
having met them but knowing what they
did I can see it in you so thank you
very much thank you and David great to
see you as always I bet you better get
your Becca presume you're off another
four games tomorrow yeah well only two
I'm afraid we can't do before but we'll
be I'll be final question for you
Arsenal Five Points clear in the Premier
League is it coming back are we going to
win the League this season I think we
have a decent chance uh because
everybody can beat everybody this year
do we need to buy a top striker in I
think they have to be bowled in the
transfer market in January would be nice
what about Cristiano Ronaldo
I'm not going to comment put him up
front with Jesus then you'd have God and
Jesus that's a good combination
that's a good one we should have thought
of that